the argument for tearing down all of
these things is that america is an evil
white supremacist terrible country
in which to quote lebron james black
people can't walk out the door without
being hunted down
that is obviously not true just a little
quick clip there was a video out of
chicago
of a cop car driving through a
neighborhood lots of people around
basically all the people around
were black and you can see on the clip
that a woman is twerking on two women
or twerking on the hood of the cop car
as it's driving
and the cops are saying get off the car
and all sorts of people
and i think basically i think every
single person maybe including the cops
in this video is black
oh i'm sorry three women are twerking on
the cop car lots of people are touching
it and the cops are doing nothing
they're just driving very slowly and
saying please please come off the car
there there is no police brutality
isolated instances
maybe as an epidemic problem it simply
doesn't exist
the police are not are not overly
forceful
if anything the police are
insufficiently forceful because they're
letting these people dance on cop cars
while they're driving around
goodness great and i get why they're
insufficiently forceful because they
know that if they use any force their
lives will be destroyed
the reality of the situation in the
united states is
very very different than the narrative
that we are told by the left
in the spirit of pride month i want you
to know i am i'm really proud
i know pride goes before destruction and
a haughty spirit before fall i am proud
though
of this youtube channel and all you
people who have subscribed that's so
great if you haven't subscribed yet
ring the bell subscribe get the
notifications head on over also to the
audio podcast
at apple podcast google play spotify
stitcher i don't know
myspace xanga live journal subscribe
there too please leave a five-star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
you